we have to end off on some good vibes  courtesy of everyone's favorite person  right now  yeah i'm talking about miles teller no  he's blowing up something  all right he's such a nice guy so just  in case you didn't get enough a rooster  in top gun maverick i hope everyone's  seen this film because it's one of my  favorites fans were treated with never  before seen footage of him rocking out  to great balls of fire while  accompanying himself on the piano yeah  i'm just saying give me all the miles  tell her content take a look  he's got a lady i can't do that have a  good weekend  bye everyone  on my brain  too much love dropped somebody insane  you broke my will  for what it thrilled goodness gracious  [Music]  kiss  [Music]  come on baby you're driving me crazy  [Music]  [Applause]  crazy  [Music]  [Applause]  up  [Applause]